what is wrong with the world ball well I
asked useless questions how deep is the
ocean how high is the sky who is John
Galt I don't know if we really are gonna
know who John Galt is by the end of this
I don't know if I should tell you I know
if I want to tell you who's John Galt
who is John Galt is what happen or is
how who's John Galt came to be that's
hard to give it a kind of a single
interpretation in Iran to Atlas Shrugged
the phrase who is John Galt has become a
cultural touchstone for futility and
hopelessness it's a world where
everything is going wrong and no one
seems to know why Why ask who is John
Galt who cares what are you gonna do a
meaning that's reflective of what's
going on in society where is our hope or
why are we in such a hopeless situation
the heroin dagny taggart is aggravated
by the hopeless futility that is
infusing the world that she's trying to
save and so the question who is John
Galt hon sir she wants to throw that
hopelessness and futility back in the
world's face what Dagny doesn't know is
that the actual answer to the question
who is John Galt is both going to
frustrate her plans to save a collapsing
world yet also show her the true key to
how to really save the world
is there any real jungle I sure hope to
her boy we need a few the political
philosophy that inspire grand to write
this novel and to imagine the character
of John Galt or unfortunately still
alive all around assistance a philosophy
that says that government has the right
and the power to shape our lives that
dictate our lives take from us the
fruits of our labor in order to pursue
what they think of as a good goal the
character of John Galt and the question
who is John Galt encapsulates the fight
against that philosophy and it's a fight
that is as relevant if not sadly more
relevant now than it was when nine ran
wrote Atlas Shrugged I think John Galt
is is sort of like all the great
embodiments of all the great characters
issue written about an example and
leadership of what we all should be like
that spirit spirit of the individual the
wall that can rise and that can achieve
anything if given the platform the force
of the individual the individual against
the state the ultimate romantic
realization of Ireland's vision of the
perfect man perfectly rational perfectly
brilliant perfectly productive